you're a stark of Winterfell you know
our words when the snows fall and the
white winds blow the lone wolf dies like
a pack suppose everybody is Charlie this
is gonna be my video all about the
origin of House Stark and how they
became kings of winter they were not
always kings in the North kings of
winter is a term of affection given to
the stark kings of the north before
Aegon's conquest so because we're
delving really deep into history I'm
doing a new round of the giveaway for
that fire and blood book the history of
the Targaryen Kings and Westeros all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video that
book is actually coming out next week so
I'll do some videos for that - no
worries even though right now on the
show Jon Snow is king in the north
technically that makes him the king of
winter but usually when people talk
about the kings of winter they're
referring to the ancient stark kings the
ones that will see from the period that
they're covering on the Game of Thrones
prequel series the George R Morton keeps
referring to as the long night even
though HBO apparently doesn't like that
title there was actually a funny moment
last week where he was talking about the
new books that are coming up he was
doing a bunch of interviews and kept
referring to the prequel series as the
long night then later in a blog post
said HBO has asked me to correct this
saying that this is not the title of the
prequel series but the Starks story as
actual rulers in the north starts with
the first king of the original first men
to cross into Westeros over the arm of
Dorne world of Ice and Fire dates that
around 12,000 years ago which would be
between 2,000 and 4,000 years before the
long night so a long time before the
events that we'll see on the prequel
series he was buried in the Great Barrow
up in Barrow town which is right here
north of the neck but south of
Winterfell after the death of that first
king as you can guess his successors
ruled the north from the Barrow lands
and became known as the Barrow Kings so
this is all happening thousands of years
before the long night there's a really
cool Easter egg scene for this during
Game of Thrones season 1 episode 2 when
Ned Stark in Robert Baratheon are
sitting in this area here this is the
Barrow lands talking about their time
during Robert's rebellion this is come
trait my mind to leave them all behind
and keep going off a month ago with you
the story of how the Starks became kings
of the north plays out in similar
rebellion fashioned so this scene is
just meant to reference that the actual
founding of House Stark is an entity
began with bran the Builder most people
think that he's called bran the Builder
because he's credited with building the
wall after the long night ended but he's
also called the quote-unquote builder
because he's credited with founding
House Stark in the construction of the
original Winterfell Castle structure the
actual architecture of Winterfell has
changed quite a bit in the last 10,000
years all this history is really
important because the prequel series
will feature House Stark and cover some
of this period so even if he's a young
man on the TV show we could see bran the
Builder in the flesh but the way that
George R Martin the books in HBO talk
about history from that period is that
it's very unreliable so you can't really
trust all the facts about how and when
in the timeline things happen so a
relatively short while after the
founding of House Stark in the
construction of the wall house stark
rebelled against the Barrow kings and
won the allegiances of the other
northern houses in a conflict called the
thousand-year war later the maesters
discovered that it only lasted for about
200 years but that's still a very long
period of time here's part of a
featurette that they released that
covers that that's narrated by the cast
members it's really cool it details
their war of conquest and how they got
the Barrow Kings to bend the knee see
what that sounds like a lot like Aegon's
conquest was happened many many
thousands of years later the North is
the oldest and largest of the Seven
Kingdoms
but how stark has not always held it
when bran the Builder razed Winterfell
and founded our line we were vassals to
the Barrow Kings who claimed descent
from the first King and thus dominion
over all the first men but after the
long night it was our house who built
the wall and set the Nights Watch to
guard the realms of men whilst our King
sat in his Barrow
my ancestors eventually revolted waging
what Singers
the thousand years war to free our lands
other families joined us recognizing
that the north is a cold and hard land
and needed a king who served its people
before himself finally the last Barrow
King bent the knee and how stark became
the kings of winter yet we were kings in
name only four by then the North had
fractures into petty kingdoms and my
ancestors would struggle to United again
for thousands of years
Roderick Stark wrestled an Ironborn Lord
for Bear Island and granted it to house
Mormont when he won a younger son of our
family Carlon stark won his own keep
after he put down a rebellion and
founded house Karstark
one of the most powerful in the north
when the man delese were exiled from the
reach my ancestors shielded them and
gave them a home at the mouth of the
white knife in return for holding the
river against pirates and invaders now
they're one of the wealthiest houses in
the north I'm not so naive to pretend
that the entire North welcome stark rule
the last wall king was slain at sea
dragon point along with all his sons and
beasts the last Marsh King died at the
hands of King Ricard stark and house
Reid has helped the swamps of the neck
ever since houses green wood towers
amber frost none survived today as more
than names in dusty old books but my
ancestors never wanted to destroy their
foes root and stem the umbers of last
half and the Glovers of Deepwood Motte
bent the knee and became loyal vassals
of House Stark
the red kings of house Bolton will
cloaks made from the skins of Stark
princes they flayed and one of the
Bolton's was even known as the red arm
because he liked to plunge an arm into
the bellies of captive Starks and pluck
their entrails with his bare hand the
North deserved to be wiped clean of them
yet my ancestor spared them after their
defeat because they believed the north
couldn't afford to fight itself any
longer time soon proved them right when
the Andal swept into Westeros they
obliterated all the kingdoms of the
first men except the north each of the
southern kingdoms fought the invaders on
its own that the north fought as one
when the Andals tried to sell up the
white knight the manderlys fell on their
ships when the Andals tried to march an
army through the neck of the weeds fell
on their soldiers King Theon Stark even
sailed his own army to the Andal
homeland for vengeance and slew hundreds
of under warriors when he returned he
planted their heads on spikes along our
coasts a warning to other would-be
conquerors the warning was heeded for
thousands of years until Aegon the
conquerer I always loved talking about
Game of Thrones history because there's
enough material just in that story of
the origin of how stark and how they
became kings to do five separate
spin-off shows just about their house
it's a good reminder of how complicated
the relationships were between the Great
Houses during the long night so most of
the time when people mentioned the long
night is only to talk about azor Ahai
the White Walkers the war for the dawn
had the war ended but there was a whole
lot of other stuff going on outside of
that let me know in the comments if you
think that we'll actually see the
founding of House Stark on the prequel
series along with the founding of House
Lannister because the way that HBO and
the other people associated with the
producers have talked about it implies
that we will getting to the season eight
of it all - there's a big question about
what's going to become of the stark name
in House Stark now that Jon has truly
been found out as Aegon Targaryen if he
survives to rule the kingdom with
Daenerys and the other surviving great
house
right now the only surviving Starks that
can pass their name on or Sansa Arya and
bran
brain is a turnip and if you go by
traditional rules of succession and how
people pass their name down through
generations only brand the male heir
would do that so the only way for the
stark name to survive is as they bend
the rules a little bit
Sansa marries another eligible bachelor
that can help her ko rule the north
while John is busy ruling the kingdom in
whatever male heirs that she has take
the stark name and keep it alive Arya
has never made any indication that she
intends to settle down That's not me and
there aren't that many eligible
bachelors amongst the main characters
that are still alive for Sansa to marry
aside from say like sweet Robin and
Gendry yeah I don't think that Arya
would be very happy with the idea of
thoughts of marrying Gendry next big
question let me know in the comments
what do you think is gonna happen to the
stark name after season 8
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big game of Thrones video
Jolin Garrow please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for my
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
preview video and click here to learn
all about the early episode 1 release
date thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight